welcome to this video playing MJ
sequeira sir IAM horses secara paolini
uh-huh ok from parents's Venezuela yep
ok let's see I'm a Catalan let's see
what is playing against it ok we get the
main line probably a 6 now
it's taking a sweet time for all those
normal moves all right he also has some
bit of a bit of a lag here yeah there
are many possible lines Bishop g5 is a
very technical line leading to end games
mostly but not not a bad line that's not
very common label of course not just not
not play too often okay what why does of
course trying to do um that's a strange
move but why does of course trying to do
is to prevent c5 and I after night
before I have quite good chances to do
that to F for now and Roxy one yeah this
looks good amongst others it's not very
well developed and this is costs time
the snotty for maneuver
rook c8 I just have 95 that's already
this look critically for black if he
does not get c5 in now now that's a very
good position c5 I just wind the pawn at
the end of seven eggs 97 I have young I
have more than one good move knight c6
books is 6am okay yeah now i have knight
c6 with good play or 93 both good 93 is
a bit more aggressive keeping pieces on
the board now it's probably better
maybe it's better I don't know it's both
us very good for wine
one possible idea of 93 also was that
something like weenie for night f4 will
attack e6 this is some soft spot blacks
camp and it's hard to hard to see a move
here what does this move 97 I just takes
e7 e 5 Queenie form yeah yeah this a
thought 11 possible way to continue but
after night after this year it's it's
it's tricky night c5 on pile up on the
sea porn now this is also hot so nice
maybe he keep display e5
yeah if he does five is not really
threatening to take i can i can improve
further
yeah that's okay on e5 I can I can also
just just I can take or III 93 that also
came
he still suffers from the c6 bond so he
does not really have soft as he really
hasn't solved his problems yet just
wonder how to how to exactly play this
93 c 593
hmm can rock the eight really maybe yeah
I need to I need to get one pair of
rooks off the system this is true and
John I'd be 7am check on d 5 34
yeah he never has moved to be eight
night and he will he will never move it
in this game I've already tried to twist
to see about that came
I don't want them I mean I can exchange
Queensland and win the end game but he
also has a bad King so look the eighth I
can just go up the ATM and tonight most
group t7s deadly we cannot protect the
night
black resigns yeah this was an opening
disaster not 94 it's really bad after
that it's it's I think already difficult
to get the playable position how do you
how do you know equalized you you never
never I get your sea por moving now yeah
this is Ella to be honest if white is a
really good technical player and in the
tournament game white wins this it's
just a win this is this is gone this is
just terrible in this position I didn't
even play it too convincingly maybe this
isn't isn't so great actually I don't I
don't know it's a it's a question maybe
I should simply play Knight c5 and
exchange the night on the seven if it
appears it's not a big deal this is also
a terrible position with them with only
heavy pieces I don't really think I
spoiled it at one point but there was
maybe more convincing play possible I
have the computer and the background he
and analysis and etcetera that I always
said dot plus 2 or plus 1 something yeah
it's really if you played this far too
far too superficial in the opening this
is just much more dangerous than that 97
is by far the best move here and then
something like this and rook c8 this is
some quite okay for black it's so very
close to equal okay thanks for watching
you